لقد استغرق الأمر سنوات من الدبلوماسية
حتى تصل العلاقات التركية الإسرائيلية إلى هذه
المصافحة، وهي الأولى على الإطلاق بين
الرئيس ريب تاي أردوغان ورئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو، ولكن
بعد شهرين فقط، اختفت النوايا الحسنة تمامًا
خارج الحرب في غزة، حيث
قدم الرئيس إروان نفسه كقائد.
وسيط سلام محتمل، ولكن مع ارتفاع عدد القتلى الفلسطينيين، ارتفع أيضًا
الخطاب الذي يتهم
إسرائيل بارتكاب جرائم ضد الإنسانية
وحتى الدفاع عن
حماس، حماس ليست
منظمة إرهابية ولكنها مجموعة تحرير
تكافح من أجل حماية أرضها
ومواطنيها الشهر الماضي، وذهب إيران إلى
أبعد من ذلك.  القول بكل وضوح وصراحة
أن إسرائيل دولة إرهابية.
قال مكتب رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو إن
إسرائيل ترفض أي محاضرات من تركيا
قائلة إن دعم إردان يبلغ عن
حالة حماس الإرهابية ويقصف
القرى التركية داخل تركيا نفسها، في
إشارة إلى الحرب التي تخوضها تركيا منذ عقود
ضد الأكراد.  لكن منذ ذلك الحين
لم يفعل إردان سوى مضاعفة نتنياهو
الذي هو جزار غزة، بالإضافة إلى كونه
مجرم حرب، فمن المؤكد أنه سيحاكم كجزار
في غزة، تمامًا كما كان موسوفيتش
يكرهان بعضهما البعض، وإلى أي مدى أثرت
هذه الحرب على العلاقات الإسرائيلية التركية
بشكل جيد.  طالما أن "ب" وأردوغان في
السلطة، فلا أعتقد أنهما سيلتقيان
مرة أخرى. لقد قطع الرئيس أردوغان رسميًا
الاتصالات مع رئيس
الوزراء نتنياهو واستدعت تركيا أيضًا
سفيرها إلى إسرائيل، لكن لا
يزال هناك مليارات الدولارات من
التجارة السنوية بين تركيا  وإسرائيل
التي لم تختف، تستمر العلاقات التجارية،
وتستمر الرحلات الجوية، وتستمر الرحلات الجوية،
ويذهب النفط إلى
إسرائيل عبر الطريق المستقيم طالما أن
تركيا وإسرائيل تعتقدان أنهما حليف استراتيجي
يحتاجان إلى بعضهما البعض، ولكن قد
تستمر العلاقات السياسية.  وتقول تركيا إنه منذ
بدء الحرب انخفضت التجارة بأكثر من
النصف بسبب المستهلكين
والتجار. وشهدت تركيا، التي استضافت
قادة حماس، مسيرات ضخمة مؤيدة للفلسطينيين
في مدن في جميع أنحاء البلاد،
وقام بعض الأتراك العاديين والمؤسسات بمقاطعة العلامات التجارية
ذات الروابط المزعومة علنًا.  لكن على الرغم من
الغضب المتزايد والخطاب الناري
خلال زيارته لألمانيا وفي
الخطابات الأخيرة، يصر إردان على أن تركيا لا تزال قادرة على
التوسط في السلام. ما يسعى إليه هو أن
يكون شريكًا في أي حل،
ولا يبدو وكأنه وصف إسرائيل بأنها
إرهابية.  من المرجح أن يعتقد أنه
يستطيع التراجع عن حقيقة أنه
لم يذهب بعيدًا، وأشك في أنه
يفكر بهذه الطريقة سواء كان
الآخرون يفكرون بهذه الطريقة أم لا، سنرى متى
تنتهي هذه الحرب على الرغم من عدم وجود  علامات على أنها
ستنتهي في أي وقت قريب سكوت ملان سي إن إن
اسطنبول